hello everyone and welcome to the fourth
and final game of the lien masters 2018
match between Ramesh Babu pragna Honda
and Wesley so as you've seen Game one
went to Prague nonde Game two went to
Wesley so again three was drawn and this
is Game four it's quite an interesting
game I'm sure you'll enjoy it but before
we check it out I do have a nice photo
challenge for you best of luck to
everyone who is the gentleman in this
photo so there you have it if you if
you've been subscribed around this
channel for some time and then you
surely have enjoyed quite a lot of
photos taken by this by this fellow here
so chances are you do know him but you
know as we are all here to increase our
vast knowledge best of luck to everyone
now onto the game problem has the white
pieces and he opens with E 4 and this
game instead of going for the Sicilian
obviously Wesley didn't enjoy that
position he got after seven moves in
Game two he goes for a five-night to
have three Knight to c6 Bishop to c4 and
Bishop to c5 we have the Joko piano game
and here Prabhu did not go for the Evans
gambit rather he went castles we have
Knight to f6 v 3 we have castles and now
a 4 and a 4 is a very nice move i I will
play this a 4 move regardless if it's a
classic game bullet game boy game rapid
game and because it's just a nice you
know space grabber if you can get a 5 in
then it's even better we have h 6 h 3 d6
just some useful pawn moves c3 and now
that c3 has been played progress
threatening before and a5 to trap the
Bishop on c5 so here we have a 5 making
room for the bishop and also preventing
before while a 5 does prevent before it
kind of weakens the b5 square so whether
you want to play a six or a five to make
room for a bishop it's just you know a
personal preference rook to e1 we had
Bishop to e6 Bishop captures pawn
captures and now Bishop to e3
we have Bishop captures rook captures
and now Queen to e8 preparing to bring
the Queen into the game so if you look
at this position
it's only moved 12 but already all four
bishops are off the board and now it's a
night's game and you know in a rapid
game nights can be very tricky night BD
- we have 90 to h5 trying to take
advantage of the weekend at Foursquare
so g3 not allowing it Queen to f7 trying
to pressure DF to pawn if the knight
ever moves then DF to pawn becomes a
target Queen to e2 bringing the Queen to
help out with the defense so now the f3
Knight can move rook a to d8 preparing
to break open the position with d5
Knight to h4 and now d5 we have rope to
f1 bringing another defender of the f2
pawn Knight back to f6 and now Queen to
d1 you have to make room for this rook
as the black will definitely push d4 so
Wesley does d4c capture some d4 would
have pawn captures on d4 and now rogue
back to e1 g5 forcing the knight back
the knight can retreat to f3 or g2 g2 is
somewhat better and here Wesley can
Wesley can decide to go either 497
followed by 95 here in pushy 5
immediately but he plays Queen to h4
Amir Queen to h5 immediately goes for
the Queen trade as he feels very
comfortable playing this position will
work we have Queen captures Knight
captures and now Knight to c4 Knight
back to f6 rope the c1 and here Knight
to d7
we have knife to a 3 and here program
Anandi is hoping to take advantage of
the weak backward c7 point perhaps with
night b5 and also the rope from c1 is
attacking it but here Knight d2 e5 by
Wesley attacking the undefended d3 pawn
so you don't have time to go night b5 we
look after d1 and now rook to d7
bringing yet another defender to the c7
pawn and also preparing to double up
rooks would rope to f7 so here not b5
wouldn't really make much sense the
black would simply improve his position
Knight f3 check King moves and then the
other book would come to f7 and now
pressure DF to pawn and this rook will
always guard at this point nicely so
after only 7
Knight to c4 the night will be much much
more useful here on c4 to defend his
position Knight to f3 check King King to
f1 and now rogue D to f7 roof - see -
preparing to defend the f2 pawn and now
King to g7 nights the e1 offering a
trade and now Knight F to e5 Knight
captures Knight captures and now rogue D
to C 1 and here it seems like a pretty
logical move to go c6 immediately but
Wesley plays an even better move c5
although the opponent currently is not
defended there's no way to take
advantage of this as you have to keep an
eye on this F DuPont and it will be it
will be much better for this point to be
on c5 as in the future
you know possibilities like c4 coming
and if pawn captures maybe d3 so a very
nice move by Wesley rook to a1 Prague
niranda here sees that his rook is
defending the f2 pawn very nicely there
is no way for black to take advantage of
this the Knight is guarding the d3 pawn
so while this rook is very useful and c2
this rule can see one isn't all that
useful you you're never gonna be able to
capture on c5 so progress idea is rook
to a1 to a3 to b3 and to try and take
advantage of this open B file perhaps
either getting drove to be six or maybe
to b5 so look to a-1 we have looked upon
to b6 now defending the pawns King to g1
now the DF one is not pinned we have h5
King to g2 King to f6 and here Wesley
sees that his position is very nice but
he wants to bring his King over to the
Queen side to help out with the defense
of the b6 pawn so rook to a3 we have
King to e7 rook to b3 and now Knight to
d7 so for the time being this Knight is
now kind of forced the kind of stuck
defending the b6 pawn but Wesley will
bring his King over to the Queen side
rope to e2 now comes King d7 night the
c2 and King comes all the way to c6 now
the d7 Knight is able to move nice to a3
we have nice to e5 and now
to see for offering a trade of knights
Knight captures pawn captures and now
comes g4 we have pawn captures pawn
captures and here we have rope to d3 so
if you look at this position the
material on the board is completely
equal but Wesley's King is much more
active than progress King and Wesley's
rooks are much more active than progress
rooks here the rook and e2 is pretty
much stuck defending the f2 pawn and the
root candy tree isn't really doing all
that much kind of controlling this f3
square so rook to h8 Wesley tries to
take advantage of the open H file room
d1 we have our rook comes to h7 rope to
g1 now and now rook to h2 check King to
f1 and here rook to f8 and still Wesley
improved his position immensely the rook
is now very nicely placed on h2 d our
troop is very active on f8 the King is
still very active here and it's not it's
not over yet but it's very hard to
defend this position with white so I
want you to pause the video here and try
to figure out try to figure out a
defensive plan here for white what would
you play with the white pieces here so
feel free to pause the video I will get
a couple of seconds as usual so you know
try to figure out some sort of a
defensive plan so for those of you who
were able to find this very nice plan
the idea is f4 if you have found this
congratulations
you know Tigran Petrosian would give you
a high-five f4 allows them allows the
white to defend because now you can't
play G captures on f3 I'm pass on
because the black rook is hanging if you
capture here rook captures then you get
King captures and then all is always
well here
rook h8 if black tries this then King
simply stops the rogue from you
infiltrating row gauge to check
roadblocks and now you can either
capture the rook and now the point and
game will be at raw or if black doesn't
like this he can play rook h3 and then
you will simply play rooms you want
prepare to bring the King over 2 G 2 and
then the king will be guarding this side
and the rook will be guarding this side
and then black will either decide if he
wants to continue or go
well for a repetition here or on the
other hand after F for maybe black will
play something like rook to h3
immediately and after I have to you will
find a very nice counter play here also
if after F for black isn't interested in
a trade like can go something like rock
h6 bring the rook all the way back but
still you're just gonna play rook f2 and
you know continue playing this game so
black wouldn't be white wouldn't be out
of the woods yet but it would be a
definite improvement here have to look
to a fate pregnant on the plate
'if I've and now Wesley capitalizes on
this if I well we could classified as a
mistake
Wesley immediately plays rook to f3 so
taking advantage of the fact that Prabhu
did not play the f4 move now rook to a3
blocked f4 but also threatens rock to be
three followed by rook to b4 as both the
c4 pawn and the a four point are
undefended and there is very little
Prague and ooh here rocked g2 was played
we have a rope to the h1 Czech rock to
g1 captures captures and now comes Rock
to b3 and like we said there's very
little problem can do here King to g2
was played preparing f3
now comes rugby for f3 is played
now look captures on c4 f captures on g4
and now d3 and now there is there is
really nothing white can do here in the
game f2 was played look the c2 offering
a rope trade of course you cannot accept
the stroke because then pawn captures
and they're at the King is simply too
far away to stop the pawn and after Roxy
to King to f3 was played now comes D to
rook captures and it was played by
pregnant uh but there is really nothing
you can do here if you block with the
King ad then d1 check King captures rook
captures rook then black is up a whole
rook or instead if you try to block with
the rook rook F 1 then you get Roxy one
still nothing you can do here King can't
come to the fence but rook captures and
then the Queen comes into the game or
you capture the point and then again
black is up a whole rook so after the to
Prague tried rook captures Sundy to rook
captures and now g5 may be trying to
pull the past pawn but Wesley simple
played King D 5 here and
Prague resigned the game so as you can
see there's really nothing to do here
after g6 is pushed King captures g7 the
rook simply defends the queening square
so after this
King to d5 progress on the game and a
very nice victory for Wesley so so as
you've seen first victory completely
deservingly went to Prague Miranda in
the second game for some reason he
missed a win and moved 8 with that
Bishop captures on f7 in game number 3
he lost but he had a better position all
the way up until he blundered and in
this game where he challenged Wesley so
to a theoretical joke Oh piano Wesley
Wesley justified his his rating and him
being in number 2 in the world rapid
rating list so yeah that's it for this
match I do hope you enjoyed the game and
the entire match all the 4 games I would
like to thank Sasha marsh which then
Phelps Matthew Hall done Dugan and they
began the Lubar ski for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check too on my
previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon I do
have one more game to show and then I'm
gonna check a couple of your suggestions
and as of Monday we start with the Bobby
Fischer story thank you all and I'll see
you soon